my gears had half been grinded well and
that's the technological gears this
whole idea of tax deductions and we walk
through this in Financial Peace
University but I'm like how bad are you
at math that you think sending ten
thousand dollars to your mortgage lender
and interest is better than sending two
thousand dollars to the IRS
that's what you're doing you're stepping
over a dollar to pick up a quarter and
thinking that you're winning and the
mortgage companies love this they're
like great send us more interest instead
of the IRS we're way better than the IRS
that's what you're doing and by the way
almost nobody itemizes on their taxes
anymore everyone takes the standard
deduction which means you don't get to
deduct your mortgage interest
almost nobody's doing this so This
theoretical idea that you're doing it
for the tax deductions is wildly
illogical